Oh going run my name is Matt welcome
back to some more happy wheels it's been
a while
I kind of feel like a chef I am playing
this sari with some kill or be killed
like [ __ ] love alright lady back up
oh I gave you a new vagina hull I'm so
sorry about that so sorry are you okay
out are you okay there are you okay I
okay
alright cool I'm gonna kill your goddamn
knees axe in my belly
alright now they're buying take the sub
right now God dad you've got me
alright [ __ ] it this is how make love
come here come and [ __ ] it that's bad
luck alright kill the man Oh
kill the man gets up Todd no I got your
leg arm or whatever it is that's what
you get you later come on I'm gonna kill
the man no no tell them at da best back
save a blade
hard ah give me a kiss okay oh yeah Oh
No
why did he do that what is going on here
come here
yes I spanked that back slap that all on
the floor slap that ah goddamnit
strong with my legs I like this I like
does it kill the man grab the sword and
yes fight to the death
woman oh yes got you now [ __ ] that's
right that's what they get for messing
with us best back
that's right Vespa mmm mmm come here mmm
come here as fat mmm yeah yeah you liked
our best bet oh yeah
you like when I rub my yeah yeah let's
do some freaky [ __ ] Vespa yeah yeah I'm
just gonna sit here what the hell is she
doing why are you dying man you're
pathetic one more inside this [ __ ]
lobbies watch out woman ah her right in
my deck ah [ __ ] yeah throw it
No
oh right in my mouth i censor it with my
arm i censor that [ __ ] because ah oh she
likes it oh shut up woman
god damnit that's me uh wait for dad
alright that's why not whoa what the
hell is going on up
let me just tap that ass mmm whoa gonna
take hotter thank you
please mommy oh yes yes thank not me oh
my god that was close
alright thank this little boy now what
am I going
whoa no don't tell me I'm stuck ah god
damn it
you got to me that girl [ __ ] clouds
man they always go and get you all right
let me just use find protection find
protection Salman take em we're all
gonna die what all right we're good very
good use our protection that's me no now
right in the deck god yes but I had
other oh yeah what am i hand doing that
no don't go back and forth dad I like
that I like got damaged why am i doing
that
don't do it I [ __ ] throw you up okay
fine I'll kids look at what it's Anton
that guy doing what I can just look at
everyone and just look at the back I did
it and you came here a lie break five
songs it became her dad
four stars alright fine I'm not like
dancer watch a bar weapon throw five
alright let's do that one I think
whoa hey everyone you right there are
you talking to me yes yo you know what
what you're awesome you are so
you know what you're gonna [ __ ] die
all of your SATA yo Joe don't speak I
don't forget about last Christmas
Christmas you gave me a piece of [ __ ]
project so I stabbed you in my dick ah
ah you're all gonna [ __ ] die
dalek el santa kit oh no no I'm gonna
get all of you putting the give me so to
get for disrespecting there you go Santa
headshot what are you doing up there
this one's for you another one let's see
if we can hear this [ __ ]
no don't you go away that's right get
the lady hey right in his deck that's a
sight you know I bad as that alright we
have two more let's kill the girl Kutch
ah ah what yes give your new vajayjay
that's right you have a new dick in bjb
that's right I guess it's like ooh what
is this
what you don't want to be anything do
you
I want to be a Barbie doll ah say that
again please
that's what you get for my son will
never be a [ __ ] Barbies okay here we
go in your training dad well that's but
they're doing you're not to share you
little [ __ ] difficult all right we got
to take it more so I think bath yes well
I did not go as planned not a lot of
things go as planned in this oh whoa
[Music]
whoa I'm a laugh Oh No why am I doing
this
that's right [ __ ] so Jeff whoa I became
a knight come on [ __ ] doing it yeah
that's right that's right [ __ ]
[ __ ] Pacific I think this one is too
big for me I'll try to finish the other
one Oh what is this
PewDiePie amnesia
barrel yes wash it fast
[Music]
you tagged that [ __ ] by keep going
Sam you can do it ah so come on well bye
can do it
that's right killer Mike difficult
alright here we go
ah-ha-ha back Mike I'm gonna be doing
yeah
ah come on we can do it son in this
position haters gotta hey mother shut up
alright cheap guy Jeff guy can go Josh
why aren't you finishing your [ __ ]
Hedgehog god damn this [ __ ] so close so
close
alright here we go talk about adventure
mr. Jha all the best
Oh big a bit long bamm-bamm bad on yes
Cossack all right dad what are you doing
with the bike inside I always had the
bike you little [ __ ]
I don't question me whoa hey Amy today
how do I eject only the boy its control
all right how can I not know that I want
to try something
Snorlax God [ __ ] off then [ __ ] that
pinata honey a dog huh
ah god damn it he keeps her whoa okay
now I will actually finish things no one
likes it's probably mine my favorite
Pokemon dams turn damn found you're late
for Pokemon in there I told him I was
fat ah don't remind me on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] off Professor Oak hey big ature I
like ya yeah I pretty car all right
whoa oh hey
cat this is type of map I would probably
take a while to finish but that's okay
factor well then I'm out of the air
don't call my mom fat
it's just shut up all right
I let pick a to rapier if you don't shut
up all right slow soy sauce ah oh I
guess I'm alive what is this [ __ ] off
misty God what was coming for her
Pikachu was my [ __ ] pick a pink pick
up shut up just bend over and take it
whoa what the hell happened there all
right we got the water badge yes pewter
City
diglettz came all right call pewter gem
hey it's all eggs dad I'm scared of onyx
he looks like a big snake and usually
don't mind big snakes do you Lee a
little help oh hey gotcha
[ __ ] off [ __ ] don't rape me oh god
dammit
that's right to get you anyone you're
gonna rape that big snake what is it
saying it's not fair we'll talk tomorrow
whoa pika what good big cat don't kiss
my bad okay I kind of like it do it
again please that's right all right it's
not fair your program is way too strong
for our next take your my badges I'm
[ __ ] stuck
hey [ __ ] off is that Han do in there oh
yeah scratch my back
oh yeah like that all right
Oh careful whoa whoa Team Rocket what
what did they say I don't remember we
have the Swedish version there's
something wrong can smell you the bag
again okay that was probably not there
ah back my arms ah God
all right that's cool da did arms I just
need one leg to finish it [ __ ] off I
don't know what those recalls all right
cool wait oh wait sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry can we get to ground please holy
[ __ ] don't explode hey brah you're also
one of my favorite Pokemon
[Music]
[ __ ] off Kellan that's right yeah no no
yes no doing [ __ ] sign too much to do
it what what I'm supposed to ride him ah
yeah I think I need to replay this I'll
see you in a second you have got to be
[ __ ] kidding man I punch god dammit
we're both [ __ ]
I hate those [ __ ] big dogs don't die
don't die thank God alright we're still
like there's some cheer Oh terrific
yeah first us it's really well made this
map alright here we go
if I can just [ __ ] finish that
dad I just want to say whatever happens
I don't give a [ __ ] what do you think
all right there we go yes yes haha looks
like we got a little [ __ ] raping time
alright do you want to side son dad it's
fine
Oh woops [ __ ] Team Rocket no one
gives a [ __ ] about those posies all
right there we go I always thought she
was really annoying James was cold but
the girl was not cool alright here we
are
[ __ ] you no don't you dare die anyone
but tell him to [ __ ] off
alright here we go now we're gonna ride
this Charizard
it's the last [ __ ] thing l ever did
I'm gonna [ __ ] mount this [ __ ] I
don't know how to do it please don't
[ __ ] off that's assault
[ __ ] off nope why are we going backwards
son [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] Mac it's
passing yeah that's right Baba yeah
[ __ ] love you for that anyway that's
pretty much it for today hope you
enjoyed even though I didn't finish
anything but maybe next episode and like
maybe if you enjoyed this kind of
convert today now see oh I wanted to
address really quick about this fan more
thing like there's nothing really I can
do about it but if you bros you don't
have to go to other people's channels
and be all like oh he's better a
petabyte is better you suck or stuff
like that i I really don't think it's
necessary to do that kind of stuff just
like I don't know this stage Chella
alright and everything will be alright
that's pretty much it
[Music]
I lost count
laughing yes